Thank You Steven thank everyone for
coming to this talk in the afternoon
and I'll be talking now about modeling
hybridization between species and how do
we reconstruct that from sets of gene
trees in fact in the previous talk we
heard the words borrowing and contact
that's the equivalent of a hybridization
between languages okay
so I there our took me in parts to my
talk first I'll start talking about gene
trees how we compute their probabilities
when there is hybridization happening
and how we infer evolutionary histories
of species from these gene trees and
then in the second part I will go to if
we have the full genome whole genome
sequences how do we annotate these
genomes to find regions in these genomes
that have undergone what we call
introgression
which is some segments of DNA get fixed
in these genomes so I'll start first we
are talking about hybridization
phylogenetic networks and how we infer
them so in the morning we heard about
incomplete lineage sorting so here we
have an example again of species tree
I'm a computer scientist but I know that
these bail papers are not different
species but it's just an illustration so
this is a species tree just imagine
these are three species there and we
have to illustration of two gene trees
growing inside this species tree if you
look at the blue one again it agrees
with the topology of the species tree if
you look at the red one it disagrees
with it okay and I will show you
actually later an exact formula for
telling us exactly the probability of
this happening so when we run into in
completely new sorting again we will be
having collection of gene trees that
disagree with each other and with the
species tree and we want to infer that
species tree and another another fact
that or factor that can cause gene Tree
in congruence is hybridization okay so
when we have hybridization thing I
imagine we have the gene flow happening
from one from one species to another
from one population to another and when
we have when this happens now if you if
you look at gene copies in this hybrid
population you can trace the evolution
of sum of genes to the left parent I'm
gonna call it left parent or some of
them are gonna go right so here in this
case if you look at the blue and
Jeanne's we exactly have the same two
topologies that I showed before exactly
the same in congruence between them but
in completely niche sorting is not
playing a role here this is because of
hybridization now where the picture gets
a bit more complicated is that
incomplete lineage so what happens if in
completely new sorting and hybridization
both happening at the same time so now
in the previous just to show you in the
previous one here if the in congruence
between the two trees if you look at
this simple case if you look at this in
congruence I take one gene here it
attaches to the right parent I take
another gene attaches to left parent so
you can imagine now one principle to
reconstruct or infer this hybridization
is just look at that in congruence where
is it going once with the left parent
once with the right parent then you can
imagine there is hybridization happening
between these two but the problem is
that if incomplete lineage sorting is
happening at the same time with it with
hybridization then then if you look at
this gene tree for example and you strip
out that network from the picture you
will see that this gene tree is actually
giving us a similar shape to the Blue
Gene tree okay so here hybridization
happening but in complete lineage
sorting is actually hiding or masking
the signal for for hybridization so the
picture gets much more complicated here
so why do we want to focus on
hybridization this is a review from 2005
that basically stated that about 25
percent of plant species and ten percent
of animal species are involved in
hybridization and I do believe actually
that these estimates are gonna go up
when we have methods to detect them
because again in the morning we heard
about concatenation and so on one of the
interesting things about concatenation
even if you have hybridization it's
gonna give you a tree and many analysis
are done with these kind of methods and
also in this in this very review by
James Merritt he actually showed the
picture of where in computation sorting
can happen so here looking at multiple
individuals or multiple Llosa from this
species some of them can trace back the
hybridization event some of them can
take the vertical
in some sense so the question here is
how do we tease apart the signal having
completely needs sorting from
hybridization so that we get the true
number of hybridization events
hybridization here imagine gene flow
happening between populations for
example or species so when we talk about
hybridization here immediately after
hybridization it's like sexual
reproduction right so if you have happy
ization between two diploid populations
then yes you have an individual all of a
sudden that has 50% of genetic material
from one parent 50% from the other
parent but the picture gets much more
complicated after that because of
selection and because of recombination
because of drift the the percentage
doesn't stay at 50% so now we look at
genomes that are mosaics have parts of
these signals of hybridization and
another interesting thing about
hybridization is that in many in some
recent examples have been shown in the
in the literature they demonstrate an
adaptive role to hybridization so for
example this is a very recent paper 2012
in nature that showed that but
hybridization happening in butterflies
and it's responsible for mimicry in
these butterflies this is here by a
colleague of mine from Rice University
where they showed that there wasn't
regression or hybridization between mice
that conferred resistance to the mice
from Jordan decides okay and they're
identified that was used here actually
is warfarin which is used also as as a
drug for humans so hybridization does
happen there is more and more evidence
for it the traditionally people think
about it happening mainly in plants but
there are more evidence now happening in
animals and again with the development
of new methods and more data more
signals going to be detected so my
interest is how do we reconstruct
evolutionary histories of species from
sequence data or from gene trees that
account for hybridization and also at
the same time account for incomplete
linear sorting so this is here a general
formula that was given by Wayne Medicine
and it makes sense it was given by
in 97 but if you think about it
basically if we have a set of of
sequence of a set of sequence alignments
from multiple loci and we are interested
in the in 97 medicine was talking about
the species 3 if we are talking about
the species 3 under maximum likelihood
we want one that maximizes basically
this this entity if we look at this we
have a product overall loss I simply
because of the assumption that the loss
I are independent and then for every
locus when we look at the sequence
alignment for it
you can now sum over all possible gene
treat apologies there is an integration
here that I'm omitting because if we
also account for all branch links we
have to do an integration and then we
have these two terms this term here is
the probability of sequences given a
tree and we know how to compute this
again we have seen in the previous talk
mention of felsenstein
algorithm for example will compute this
this entity and this has been our focus
because this is what's missing now under
for incomplete linear sorting if gene
trees disagree with species trees only
because of incomplete lineage sorting
then this has been worked out this this
probability what we have been focusing
on is how do we compute this probability
if there is also hybridization as well
okay now if in the morning we heard
about about approaches where the gene
trees are reconstructed first and again
the talk after this we will hear about
gene trees reconstructed first if we
have that then we can factor out
completely this issue of of sequences
and integration over gene trees and we
can basically focus on the probabilities
of the gene trees okay so the question
is how do we compute this probability of
gene tree given a speech history so here
in the case of species tree and then I
will move on to that one how what
happens when there is hybridization so
here there's no hybridization in
completely sorting is going to happen
look at the species tree here on three
species ABC and I have an example of a
gene tree there ABC or so okay so gene a
is taken from species a and so on now if
we look at if we look at these two
koalas and events basically that the two
genes from a and B coalesced at node X
and then we
have not why and I'm focusing
exclusively on topology and I'm ignoring
branch lengths on the gin tree there are
two possible ways to explain that gene
tree appearing inside this fish history
either a beak or less on branch one so
node X is mapped to not one and then Y
is mapped to two or X happens here so a
and B coalesce here at this point and
then seek Wallaces with them so this is
what we call koalas and history so there
are two possible koalas and histories
and if we if we look at a vector whose
size is the number of internal nodes and
the gene tree and we put the vet the
entries in that vector are basically the
branch numbers from the species tree we
can now represent each callers and
history is one such with one such vector
okay so this vector one two telling me
that one embedding of that gene tree
inside the spacious tree is map X 2 1 Y
2 2 this is saying x - 2 y 2 - and there
are no other koalas and histories for
this gene tree ok because I'm just
focusing on the topology if we focus on
time then the times of these events are
gonna dictate where these things happen
so once we take these once we think
about this call a set of callers and
history so I'll denote by H sub sy of GT
the set of all possible callers and
histories that can explain the gene tree
then the the probability of observing
any gene tree given the species tree is
given by this quantity so this is now
the probability of a gene tree given a
species tree and its branch lengths and
I will illustrate I will describe what
this is this means but the main the main
thing to notice here is that this
probability now is a summation over all
possible coalescence histories no I
saying we are saying what is the
probability of the gene tree it's
basically sum over all possible ways of
embedding the gene tree and then compute
the probability of that embedding okay
now the probability of them bidding is
nice to compute because we can take it
it's independent for the branch if so
you can compute it for every branch
individually and take the product so
what what are these terms that are
happening that are used here so suppose
we have a branch B here whose their
length is lambda B so this is a branch
in the species tree okay and we are
going to focus just on what's happening
within this branch and see what is the
probability of that thing happening so
imagine here that we have five lineages
in coming into the edge because we are
looking at the Koala sent from the
leaves towards the the root five of them
coming and two of them exiting if this
scenario happens then for sure you have
to have three koalas and events right so
to reduce it from five to two we have to
have five quarters and three-quarter
cent events so the previous term and the
formula was what is the probability that
three quarters and events will happen
within this time and the second term
which is the project that we take the
product of the two once we have these
three events happening we want them to
happen in exactly this way that they
give rise to the exactly this topology
right because many ways of three three
quarters and events could happen but we
want the specific ones so the first the
first term is what is the probability of
these three a koala sentiments happening
assuming that three did happen here
again we denote by this UB of H is under
this call isn't history H how many how
many lineages are incoming into this
this branch which is five how many of
them exiting would be - sorry - and now
we can say these two terms that were in
the previous formula WB of H how many
possible ways this these specific koalas
and events could have happened there are
three of them because we can think about
one and two one has to happen before two
but three could happen before one
between them or after them so if we put
this in total order we have three
possible ways now and the other time we
have to say these three force the koalas
and events to happen in exactly the same
way to give rise to the gene tree that
we have we cannot change that
but there's another term these are three
out of how many possible ways we could
have had three and the formula for that
basically gives us hundred eighty okay
so these two terms are if when I divide
this by this is going to give me the
probability of these specific koalas and
events
and the other term in the formula was
puv over time t is that what is the
probability of you lineages entering the
branch v8v
lineages exiting from the branch if the
branch had length T and this formula was
derived in the mid fort in the mid-80s
actually and it has been used in this
context and many other contexts so these
two this is this tells me if you have a
branch of length T what is the
probability of a certain number of
quarters and events happening this
formulas gonna give us that and the
previous slide basically told us for
this specific number of collison events
what is the probability that the
specific pattern of koalas and events
will happen so these will give us
basically the probability of gin tree
given speeches tree some of you might
not have seen it in the most general
case so here this is a 3 a 3 species
case and we heard about in the morning
so this is human Chamber Ella and if you
were going to look at every part there
are three possible gene trait apologies
here again one that puts human chimp
versus gorilla human gorilla versus
chimp and sham gorilla versus human then
that formula is going to reduce to these
three values here okay and these three
values again the main factors that
change things are the length of this
branch that separate the most recent
common ancestors this and this the
length of the branch which in number of
generations T 2 T 2 minus T 1 divided by
n which is the population size or the
width of this branch okay and if we want
to visualize these three probabilities
this is the value of the three
probabilities as the as this quantity
increases okay and this kind of figure
in this kind of illustration actually
explains why often in phylogenetics
researchers don't focus on incomplete
lineage sorting because if your sampling
is done in such a way that this branch
is very long you are probably operating
in a zone here where this is not really
an issue a few sample enough genes then
the gene with the highest frequency
might be indicative of the species tree
although there is one important caveat
here is that this result is true for
three species but there was a similar
paper a few years ago bye-bye
Rosenberg and James Dignan that showed
under certain circumstances that gene
three with the highest probability is
not necessarily the one that agrees with
the species three once you go beyond
three species but for three species that
doesn't arise that clean tree with the
highest probability is going to be the
one that agrees with the species tree so
the question is what happens when we say
okay we have hybridization and in
completely new sorting now what is the
probability of this gene tree growing
inside this evolutionary history so the
first thing is that when we have
hybridization the evolutionary history
of species is no longer a tree and we
have to go to phylogenetic networks and
this is the definition that we use in
our work for phylogenetic network and
it's very important to give that
definition because phylogenetic networks
have been mentioned in in thousands of
papers now and I think there are at
least 20 different definitions probably
some of them are very close to this some
of them have nothing to do with this all
of them are called phylogenetic Network
but everyone introduces their own their
own definition and we are all guilty of
that so phylogenetic networks here are
basically the topology of a phylogenetic
network is modeled by a rooted directed
acyclic graph and we have we have
basically the root we have this type of
nodes within degree two that describe
for example in our case hybridization
but if you are thinking about
recombination it will be recombination
and so on and we have the leaves as
before with the trees in addition to
this we have also to have when we add
because we are doing the probabilistic
inference we have to have branch lengths
on these on these branches and in
addition we have also probabilities
associated with these nodes that we call
inheritance probabilities so this
inheritance probability for example for
this node here I have gamma which
basically means that if I'm looking
backward in time and genes copied from
these species and I go backward in time
when I'm tracing the evolution of a gene
from B once I get to this node I have
probability gamma of going left or
probability one minus
of going right for that so when we do
the inference of these networks we want
to get the topology we want to get up
the branch lengths and we want to get
these gammas and if we have K of these
nodes we have to have K of these gammas
so one of them main one of the main
concepts in in networks that have been
used extensively for the last 20 years
in terms of how do we reconstruct
Network how do we evaluate Network how
do we analyze networks is by looking at
something that we call trees induced by
networks or trees displayed by networks
of trees contained by networks and the
concept is very simple if you have a
network you have do notes of in degree 2
for every possible way of for it look at
every node M in degree 2 and remove one
of the two parents from that to parental
ages so you can remove this and best
you'll get that tree if you remove this
and this you will get another tree and
so on so when you have two of them you
have four trees in this and if you have
K of them in general you have on the
order of 2 to the K it can be smaller
than that okay but this is the notion of
induced trees and if we have only
hybridization then each one of these
trees should be able to capture any of
the gene genealogies in the evolutionary
history because we don't have in
completely new sorting so every gene you
trace it back it should trace one of the
parents and Qualis at the most recent
common ancestor we should not have any
noise in the picture however the problem
is that this notion of induced trees
does not capture the full story when ILS
is present okay so here if you look just
at this case I have I take one copy of a
gene from each of these four species and
I trace back the evolution of this copy
of SIP from C and one from B if you look
at B it goes left and if you could look
at C it goes right in this case the tree
that should capture this as B is
attached to a and C is attached OD thus
that species tree okay so this is a case
here where the the notion of induced
trees is not sufficient to capture the
evolution histories of genes so for us
the solution that we did for this
problem is that instead of looking at a
network and it's induced
which is not sufficient we convert the
network into a special tree it's one
network to one tree not multiple trees
that we call multi multi label tree and
we consider all allele mappings of the
gene tree to that the to that mall tree
and then we compute the probabilities
the nice thing about going from the
network to tree is that we have lots of
techniques that work nicely on trees
from doing parse them into doing
likelihood and doing all these kind of
calculations on trees so representing
the network as a tree immediately
translates or transfers all these
techniques to work on these trees but
there will be just one one detail that
we have to take care of in this case
that I will describe so I'll avoid that
one there but I'll illustrate what we
mean by this multi labeled tree so
that's a network that's given here and
this is the multi labeled the tree
representation of the network so it's
very easy to go from here to here in
this one simple way is just both
bottom-up whenever you see a node like
this just copy the entire subtree under
that node but attach it once to the left
once to the right you will get this and
you keep repeating because if you have
more and more you can repeat this
process so what you end up with is one
tree that represents this network but
this is not that traditional
phylogenetic tree because the leaves are
not uniquely labeled okay so this
subtree here under under the
hybridization event is now two copies of
it and BC and BC so the issue that
arises now when we have this small tree
is that instead of looking at this
network and trying to figure out where
the gene genealogy how it does in gino's
it traces inside this Network now once I
map the alleles to to the leaves of the
tree then I think is that with a tree
there's always a unique path from a leaf
to the root okay so what is this concept
of allele mappings when I have this
small tree description of the network
and I have a gene tree here if we look
at the gene tree for example it has in
this case we sample two alleles B 1 and
B 2 B 1 and B 2 could both be sampled
from this from here or here or B 1 B 2
or B 1 B 2
okay so the little mapping and each
allele mapping is supposed to capture
one of these scenarios so these are all
the possible allele mappings that I can
find for for a gene tree given this at
this speed Moultrie if we have b1 b2
they can again both of them to this B or
to each one of the bees or to this okay
and as we have the C also the C because
we have one allele we sampled one allele
from C it can set me up to this one or
to this one now the nice thing about it
is that the probability of a gene tree
given the network is now the summation
over these allele mappings with the
probability of a gene tree given this
small tree okay now this I showed that I
showed a formula earlier with the
probability of a gene tree given a
species tree now we had to tweak that it
turned out to be a bit of a challenge
but we had to tweak that so that this
probability now applies okay now why did
we have to tweak it because if you map
b1 to this B and B to to this B and then
they traced back to different two
different trajectories then implicit in
this you have to account for the fact
that implicit in this the fact that b1
and b2 did not call this on this branch
right because if you don't account for
that you are not getting actually the
correct probability so since I forced
them to take different paths then I have
to basically in the probability I have
to put a term for the fact that b1 and
b2 could not call us here okay so that
was the detail that we had to account
for and to get it done basically we have
to introduce some mapping that takes
care of this very nicely and that
generalizes the probability that I
showed before to this again it looked a
bit more complicated but the fact is
just about the reason it looks like this
is because we have to again to account
for these copies that came from the same
species but now we are forcing them to
take different paths okay and again in
the morning we heard about the issue of
error in the gene trees
that gene trees are not necessarily
estimated correctly we have two
heuristics that to deal with these
things so that when our implementation
we don't assume that gene trees are
binary or the gene trees are correct you
can use gene trees that you have for
example obtained from mr. base and use
the posterior two to weight these gene
tree topologies or another thing is that
if you are doing bootstrap then you can
contract all the branches that have low
bootstrap in the gene trees turning it
into a byte non binary tree and then
when you are doing the inference or the
computation of probability you can now
find a resolution that is probably
better that it's the the phylogeny is
going to constrain now of course our
main interest is to do the inference of
this species phylogeny which is the in
our case the phylogenetic network so I
have a set of gene trees this big G and
I want to find the phylogenetic network
that optimizes the or maximizes the
likelihood and our approach to this is
basically to do what people have been
doing in for in the case of phylogenetic
trees for decades which is don't try to
solve it exactly without doing any
search but we do search in the network
space now now in the case of
phylogenetic trees there are many ways
of doing the tree space here we have to
come up with with our own way of
searching the network space and the way
we do it is we do it in a controlled
fashion we divide the space of networks
into layers where this layer has the set
of all trees this has the layer of all
networks with one reticulation to
reticulation three and one of the
interesting things that came out once we
started thinking about this is that if
you think about trees if you look at in
taxa the number the number of branches
you can have in a tree within taxa if it
is rooted is in minus two and minus two
right so you have a 2n minus two
branches in a tree with intact so that's
the maximum number you can have because
you can have non binary trees the
problem with networks is that in theory
this is this space is infinite you can
keep partitioning the branches here
making them shorter and shorter as much
as you want in theory right so this that
you don't you cannot even limit it in in
theory unlike the case of trees
and the the major issue that arises here
is that once you start going from this
layer to this and so on
now the model becomes more complex and
it starts fitting the data better and
the the trivial answer will always come
back as you know just take the network
that's most complex in the analysis but
we do this analysis here because when we
have these operations that allow us to
jump from one layer to next we actually
try to wait this kind of operations so
that we don't keep taking this with with
high frequency and the other thing is
that to allow for this search we have to
speed up the F calculations something
I'm not going to show here which is that
we can compute the probability of a G
entry given a phylogenetic network in a
much faster way without having to
explicitly account for all koalas and
histories so we do a technique that's
used on something called ancestral
configurations and that speeds up the
computation and again the last thing we
have to account for is the model
complexity again if you want a network
that fits the data better just keep
adding reticulation x' okay and whether
it is under likelihood or possum you
just keep adding nodes and things will
get better and here we just we
experimented with information criteria
like akaike information criterion bi C
and so on but we also devised a new way
of inferring these probabilities using
cross-validation where we learned the
network from a subset of the data and
then use the remaining subset that the
test subset because we know the
frequencies of gene trees in it and we
have learned a network with we compute
the probabilities of the gene trees now
we can compare the probability under the
model we learned to the frequencies in
the test data set and in fact this turns
out to work well lecture this
cross-validation so here this is small
the next slide I'm gonna show the bigger
picture of this data set so here this is
an analysis of a data set of five mouse
genomes the mice were sampled from
Germany France Czech Republic Kazakhstan
and China this data set of of mice has
been there have been many hypotheses
about about hybridization happening
between them and the research papers
have been actually talking about
hybridization between every pair of
species there
so it's happening like everywhere these
are results that are from coming from
our analysis here this is just for
exploration we are showing the top
networks with zero reticulation than the
top with one with two with three and so
on because again in exploration we have
did not want to stop the method to see
what's happening based on the
cross-validation results the the best
result is obtained when we have networks
with two reticulation x' in this case
and it performs much better than AIC and
b IC and this is a better schematic of
these results where we show that for
this data set of mice we actually
hypothesize that a lot of the in
congruence is due to incomplete lineage
sorting and you don't need tons of
hybridization events to hybridization
events are sufficient and this was done
using about 20,000 genomic regions from
the genomes because we had to sample
them far apart to be independent what
these circles mean is that in our
analysis we find that we can get the
target of the hybridization with
accuracy with confidence we are sure it
was it happened from here to here but
for the source it's interesting that the
likelihood computed calculate the values
whether the source is here or here or
here are almost the same
so we basically present this as a
consensus of these results and the same
thing with this
we also infer the amount of of gene
trees that are hybridized about six
percent and here about four percent
between these and these are very these
are consistent with all the findings
that are recorded in the literature but
this is a much simpler explanation okay
we have we analyzed the yeast data set
also again we heard about concatenation
in the morning this is a yeast data set
of him from a famous study where the
sequences were concatenated and a
species tree was obtained with 100%
bootstrap using our analysis actually
find that hybridization an evolutionary
history with hybridization and and
longer branches explains the data much
better we also have calculations of gene
trees when the branch lengths are also
incorporated so everything I talked
about now is topologies but we have also
did it for branch links as well which
I'm not going to talk about but it's
very important
because now you know with Felton Stein's
algorithm and these methods that we have
you can do the full full inference all
the way from sequences in theory because
once you implement this this is gonna be
a nightmare computationally so in the
last few minutes I'm just going to talk
about the second part which is much
shorter is about how do we use these
networks if we have an inference of
Network how do we annotate genomes for
introgression
and the point here is that if you look
at the genomes they are basically data
that was generated from this stochastic
model a network where genes we have
these gene genealogies are evolving
within that and on top of them we have
sequences evolving right so we have now
we get all these genomes and unlike the
previous part where we were taking you
know regions from the genome that are
independent building trees and we want
to get the network now the point is that
if some if the biologist has this data
set of genomes and they know there's
introgression some segments of DNA that
are interests we want to annotate these
genomes so our approach is again to use
that to use this network concept and the
trees this kind of trees here that are
the trees inside we along with with with
the allele mappings and our problem of
interest is that if I am if I'm here I
have the input in part a there this set
of GIS genomes with all the DNA in them
and if I you know also something about
these trees inside the network can I
predict for every for every site in the
genome can I predict the probability or
the probability for the for the site
coming from what which one of these
trees and which one of these gene
genealogists because once I do this then
I can basically Thresh out this or do
whatever I want with it so that I say
that okay I believe that the first site
above down this local genealogy inside
this tree so it's in not involved in
hybridization or down this genealogy and
down this tree which basically says it
is involved in hybridization and our
approach to this is to combine hidden
Markov models with with these
phylogenetic networks so now in this
case since I have two possibilities for
the for the phylogenetic network either
from B go left or go right then I can
have two rows of states this is what
these two rows of states correspond to
so this is the states where things are
going left here these are the states
where things are going right but even
when you go right you can still have all
possible gene three gene treat apologies
right because even this red one
could have come right and not call us
here and call us in different ways there
so now every every state here has a
local gene genealogy and three tax that
we have three possibilities if this was
four we will have 15 states because
there are 15 topologies and we'll still
have 15 if this network had more
reticulation then we will have more rows
this is how this mother is gonna blow up
basically with more reticulation and so
on so now we have when we have this this
model basically switching within these
kind of states with switching within
this draw or within this row corresponds
to basically crossing recombination
breakpoints and and and having in
congruence because of incomplete and
it's sort of thing if you switch between
these two rows it is we believe that
this would be switching because of
introgression
and again in the general in the more
general case where we have more
articulations then you can have multiple
rows and more switching and then when we
have this formulation then the problem
of interest is solved really by looking
at the posterior decoding which we can
can be solved with forward and backward
algorithms so now with the probability
that the side G is coming on gene in
local genealogy TX and from parental
species trees iy is basically obtained
using the posterior decoding so we have
implemented all this and we have
analyzed a set of of mouse genomes and
the genomes that we look at here are two
male species one is called mus spíritus
and the other one is mus musculus
domesticus and the reason we focus on
this is because and as i shortened up in
the beginning the study by michael cohen
and his colleagues where they showed
this introgression
adaptive integration involving vcore see
one gene was happening actually between
must British and mass domesticus and but
they are they just focused on one region
and they investigated experimentally
these results here show our scan of
introgression in chromosome 7 in Mouse
and this is region that's highlighted
here is the region where B core c1 is so
we our method detecting this region and
it's actually the largest region that it
detected to be interests and big or c1
is here and there are actually a few
more that we detect and the results can
be summarized we found 19 regions in the
genomes that are interests 5 of them are
longer than 1 mega base pairs and 14 of
them are shorter than that the length
matters it's very important a very
powerful signal actually you can talk
about the age of integration and so on
the interest one of interesting things
is actually we found that all the
introgression segments to be to be
concentrated in 5 chromosomes i think
the mouse has about 19 chromosomes we
found absolutely no signal of
integration and the other ones so to
summarize if we view phylogenetic
network as a collection of these
Moultrie and allele mapping pairs this
provides us with a natural way to extend
the multi species koala scent for
computing gene probabilities and ILS and
hybridization also this allows us to
extend the hidden Markov models to
annotate genomes in the presence of
introgression as well a major challenge
now for us is definitely computational
requirements I cannot do this hidden
Markov model approach on 10 genomes at
for example or even the inference of
networks we cannot do it on 50 taxa at
this point all these methods everything
that's described is implemented it's
open source in Java and publicly
available and just one last summarizing
concept that I want to emphasize is that
there is this I would say tension
between the three camp and the network
camp and there are more papers appearing
recently talking about network thinking
and so on I believe that the truth lies
somewhere in between them the things
that if you stick with methods that
construct trees you are going to get
that tree whether you like it or not
even if there's tons of hybridization
and but the problem with networks also
and I think this has been stopping the
community from adopting them the problem
with networks is that you can keep going
right as much as you want and this is
actually actual analysis of the yeast
data set with hundred six loss I if you
invoke every in Congress there is
because of
reticulation you won't get a very
complex picture that's not easy for
biologists to to accept right but if you
go somewhere in between unusable of a
model that will incorporate both this is
what we obtain actually there is still a
lot of the in congruence is due to
incomplete lineage sorting but we infer
actually that many of the branches are
too long for incompletely sorting to be
the issue instead it isn't regression
and this has been worked with with the
James Declan from University of
Canterbury in New Zealand and with my
group members at Rice and I acknowledge
the funding sources and I thank you for
your attention
can you clarify what your meeting by a
hybridization oh so for me I'm a
computer scientist so by all this
they're thinking correctly so
hybridization is the event that happens
between the species for example again we
have sexual reproduction between two
members from two species two populations
and so on then you have again that
individual with the 50% material from
the parents introgression to me the way
we look at integration we understand
integration it is the integration of
genetic material in the genome right so
we are looking at X 10 genomes today you
can have hybridization and because of no
non-adaptive you know their patient
because of drift and so on you might
after actual after some some generations
you might not see anything in the genome
left
no no that's generating a new species is
hybrid speciation which is a special
case of hybridization here I'm not
talking about hybridization getting
giving rise to a new species and this is
why I try even to draw it I mean if the
drawing is not gonna make any difference
inside in terms of the data structure or
the representation but usually we try to
differentiate between hybrid speciation
in the drawing so this will be hybrid
speciation in the things that both are
equal contributors and and this is the
hybrid species and usually you'll see
something like this some sort of gene
flow happening from this population to
this and again the genetic material is
going to be part of it is coming from
here part of it coming from here but
this is not a new species but hybrid
hybrid speciation does happen but not
every hybridization event is going to
give rise to have the hybrid speciation
so your model assumes these
hybridization events as really as
discrete events in time right so but if
in reality you have a very low rate of
Qi flow between two species so very good
question because this is sometimes I get
this question about how does this differ
for example from isolation with
migration and all the work that can be
that models gene flow explicitly so this
is a very abstract model we are not
going after gene flow rate the rates or
anything like that
but when we do the inference when we are
searching the network space nothing
stops our our procedure and in fact our
implementation allows for this kind of
scenario right it's gonna allow him
because these are two different times
and so on so you can imagine that
different high position events happening
here back crossing and so on these are
allowed by the search and this is why I
say it that thus the space of our
genetic network is actually infinite
because I can keep even partitioning
this more and more so we do all of this
it is still discretized in some sense we
are not saying I'm not imagining it here
like there's a queue appear and again
gene flow happening continuously within
that but you would stop discount for
this right so that if you have very many
hybridization events and there should be
some statistical way to weigh this down
in your framework like going in favor of
this instead of this yes no we don't
have you don't have know but this is
again this is where the I put one slide
in passing and it did not talk about it
in detail so there is if you if you
start thinking about the more the more
refined model whether you look at the
gene trees with their branch lengths and
so on I do believe that gene trees with
branch lines are going to give you more
power and you're going to be able to
detect more of these scenarios than gene
3 topologies alone and the only reason
that currently we don't focus on that
and implementation is because I believe
it's very hard to estimate these branch
lines
I mean we are already dealing with
hybridization in an incomplete lineage
sorting an error in the gene 3 estimates
and if we put branch links into the
picture that's a fourth source of error
as well so I don't see our model foot
taking this in favor of this it all
depends on the likelihood and if we use
cross-validation which one gives us a
better a better predictive power in some
sense but in our implementation no we do
not have to favor this in place of this
I mean for AIC for exam yeah I see and
be I say we look at what are the
parameters in the phylogenetic Network
for us it is the the number of branches
because they're going to give us branch
lengths each one of them and for for
this nodes of in degree 2 we add one
parameter for each because that's the
gamma so this will be the number of
parameters for B I see what we are what
we are using also for the number of
samples is as the number of gene trees
in this case I mean this one because of
the little likelihood is in the in the
formula I mean you will have the penalty
coming from the number of parameters but
you add one more parameter and then your
likelihood might drop significantly in
fact actually we are not I am NOT coming
here to advocate the IC or you can have
a low rate if you go in it's still just
one parameter it's just a different
parameter yeah many parameters so it
looks yeah yeah but we don't again this
is where this is a much more abstract
than all these approaches that take very
population genetic approach and and go
after these rates and the different
rates as well
okay so there's no question